und darüber welche Schrauben man da
drehen muss kann ich jetzt sprechen bei
unserem Studio hier in Bonn Nato-General
ade Egon Rams der Rams ist es eine
komplizierte Problematik insbesondere
wenn man nicht Militär ist aber wir
waren es dennoch auf Versuch an klein
wenig aufzulösen grundsätzlich mal eine
Einschätzung wir sind jetzt nach einem
Jahr Krieg in und gegen die Ukraine und
wir fragen uns manchmal wo stehen wir
eigentlich was ist in diesem Jahr
passiert und erreicht worden guten
Morgen Frau Holland zunächst alles Gute
zum Weltfrauentag auch für die anderen
zuschauernde das und dann zur Position
völlig anderes Thema hätte ich bei einer
gesagt wir sind in einer Situation dass
wir wir heißt alle westlichen Staaten
und insbesondere die europäische Staaten
nach dem Ausbruch des ewigen Friedens in
den 90er Jahren sowohl unsere Bestände
an Waffensystem runtergefahren haben als
auch dann die Munition Bevorratung
runtergefahren haben früher war es
üblich dass man einen 90 Tage Vorrat
hatte 90 Tage ist eine Menge und man hat
dann angefangen Munition abzugeben an
die Ukraine auch mit den Waffensystem es
wurde gerade den Beitrag die 155 mm
Munition genannt das ist die Artillerie
Munition unter anderem für die
panzerhaube bis zu 2000 aber auch für
andere Haubitzen die in der Ukraine
eingesetzt werden und es besteht ein
großer Bedarf aufgrund des großen
Beschusses und unsere Lagerungen sind
runter
ja eigentlich und einfach abgesenkt
worden und die Produktionskapazitäten
der Industrie sind in vergangenen Jahr
oder vergangenen 20 Jahren ebenfalls
abgesenkt worden von daher tut sich da
eine Notlage auf die schwierig in den
Griff zu kriegen ist Notlage ist ein
ziemlich umfassender und auch ein sehr
deutlicher Begriff ja general deswegen
noch mal die Frage also wir haben ja
eigentlich in Deutschland schon im
letzten Jahr diesen doch enormen
Beschluss gefasst ist Sondervermögens
des Aufbaus und der Frage dass wir uns
nicht nur finanziell sondern eben auch
materiell in Punkte Verteidigung neu
ausstatten können ist dann nichts
passiert haben wir irgendwas
sprechen zu wollen ja wir haben die
Unterstützung zugesagt wir haben von der
zeitenwände gesprochen aber wir haben
dann auch lange darüber diskutiert in
dem Fall fast vier fünf Monate was wir
denn für Gerät liefern an die Ukraine
und ich bleibe bei dem Beispiel der
Panzer Haubitze 2000 dazu haben uns dann
im Sommer entschlossen haben dann
ukrainische Soldaten ausgebildet und ich
gebe Ihnen Recht mit ihrer Feststellung
das ganze ist vor mehr als einem Jahr
passiert oder hat sich entsprechend
entwickelt und von daher hätte man
eigentlich vor einem Jahr der deutschen
munitionsindustrie sagen sollen schmeißt
die Bänder an erhöht die Produktion geht
möglicherweise in einen
Mehrschichtbetrieb rein das ist nicht
erfolgt und wenn ich das noch ein
bisschen weiter detaillierter analysiere
komme ich sogar zu dem Schluss das
offensichtlich andere europäische
Staaten auch der deutschen
munitionsindustrie also zum Beispiel
Rheinmetall einen entsprechenden
aufteilt haben während wir noch drüber
nachgedacht haben also die Diskussion
jetzt nach einem Jahr Krieg kommt ein
bisschen spät und alles was man jetzt so
beobachten kann ein kleinen Meldungen
also man fragt die Schweiz ob man
ausgemusterte Panzer zurückkaufen darf
und all diese Dinge gehen jetzt da rein
sozusagen in diese verlorene Zeit unter
können darunter mit soziiert werden wenn
wir jetzt ganz generell noch mal fragen
es wird unheimlich viel Munition
verbraucht die blank stehen wir wie lang
steht die NATO da
also wenn man Kenntnisstand richtig ist
mit aller Vorsicht würde unser
Munitionsvorrat für zwei Tage reichen
das sind nicht die 90 Tage die vorhin
angesprochen hatte von daher haben wir
einen Bedarf einmal um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen das ist im Augenblick das
dringendste würde ich sagen und wir
müssen weiter darauf achten dass wir
unsere Munitionsbestände für unsere
truppenteilung Einheiten das gilt wieder
für die gesamten europäischen
NATO-Staaten entsprechend auffüllen
Munition ist das eine Mann und Maus ist
das andere wir haben gerade Boris
Pistorius angesprochen auf seinen
Truppenbesuch an der Ostflanke da hätte
natürlich Litauen ganz gerne irgendwie
so eine Bataillons Stärke 5000 Mann er
war zögerlich
das sind natürlich auch immer diese
Fragen Kriegseintritt und so weiter wie
wie heißt man dran wo sehen Sie die
Schwelle also vom Kriegseintritt sollte
man in diesem Falle nicht reden die NATO
ist ein Verteidigungsbündnis und die
Nato hat während des ganzen
zurückliegenden Jahres sorgfältig darauf
geachtet immer wieder deutlich zu machen
das ist darum geht dass die NATO NATO
Territorium verteidigt und die Natur hat
bisher noch kein und angegriffen wenn
man das mal in dieser Form so sagen darf
davon daher sage ich mal sehe ich dieses
Risiko sehe ich nicht so es muss an
diesem Thema schlicht und einfach weiter
gearbeitet werden die NATO muss ihre
Position in der Richtung halten und wir
müssen vielleicht auch ein bisschen
berücksichtigen dass der Wladimir Putin
der Präsident der Russischen Föderation
das mit Argumenten ausnutzt die auch bei
uns in die Öffentlichkeit ganz bewusst
reingebracht werden Stichwort
Kriegsgefahr NATO Kriegstreiber wir
fühlen uns umzingelt und dergleichen
Dinge mehr das entspricht einfach nicht
den Tatsachen wir können noch einen
kurzen Schlusspunkt machen Herr general
China Peking ist für uns alle nicht gut
lesbar aber wie gefährlich ist das
sozusagen die möglichen Überlegungen mit
Waffen zu unterstützen also wenn ich die
letzten Erklärung von China sehe bis hin
zurück zum G20-Gipfel vor einigen Monat
muss man jetzt schon fast sagen dann ist
China im Augenblick noch zwar in einer
unterstützungsposition für Russland aber
bisher in diesen Fragen noch nicht aktiv
geworden und von daher glaube ich das
beispielsweise auch der Hinweis von Präs
t oder von den Amerikanern die sollten
sich aus dem Thema raushalten sonst
würden weitere Sanktionen holen ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt ist in China deutlich zu
machen dass man sich aus diesem Konflikt
zumindest mit aktiven Handlungen
raushalten sollte im Hintergrund ziehen
die Chinesen ihre Fäden darüber müssen
wir uns im Klaren sein ganz herzlichen
Dank für diese Analyse heute hier am
Internationalen Frauentag Natur general
ade übernachten